lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar la velocidad final cuando este
objeto toca esta plataforma que de hecho
se me olvidó que lo calcularemos en el
vídeo anterior y para esto lo que vamos
a hacer es encontrar los componentes
horizontal y vertical del vector
velocidad final para reconstruirlo y
encontrar esa velocidad nuestra
velocidad total final bueno el
componente horizontal es sencillo de
hecho aquí ya lo tenemos 30 por coseno
de 80 grados y esto no va a cambiar en
ningún momento del tiempo así que este
va a ser el componente horizontal de
nuestra velocidad cuando el proyectil
aterrice ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es encontrar el componente vertical otra
cosa que encontramos en el vídeo
anterior es el tiempo en el que el
proyectil va a estar en el aire este
valor de acá y tenemos una manera de
encontrar nuestra velocidad final usando
nuestro tiempo en el aire vamos a hacer
un poco de espacio aquí abajo para
calcularlo
y ahora que vamos a estar trabajando con
los elementos verticales de la velocidad
final vamos a poner aquí vertical y
suponiendo que nuestra resistencia al
aire es cero nosotros sabemos que el
componente vertical de nuestro cambio en
la velocidad va a ser igual al
componente vertical de la aceleración
esto multiplicado por nuestro cambio en
el tiempo que es este valor y cuál va a
ser nuestro cambio en la velocidad bueno
va a ser nuestra velocidad final
vertical menos nuestra velocidad inicial
vertical y de hecho nosotros ya
conocemos este valor de nuestra
velocidad inicial vertical es este 29
punto 54 que es nuestro 30 por seno de
80 grados así que esa velocidad es 29
puntos 54 metros por segundo
así que esto lo podemos sustituir aquí
29 puntos 54 metros por segundo
eso es igual a nuestra aceleración en la
dirección vertical que como está
haciendo hacia abajo va a ser negativa
menos 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
multiplicado por nuestro tiempo en el
aire que es de 5.67 segundos ya no
podemos despejar nuestro componente
vertical de la velocidad final si
sumamos 29 puntos 54 en ambos lados de
esta igualdad nos va a quedar el
componente vertical de mi vector final
va a ser igual
29 punto 54 metros por segundo menos 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado por 5
puntos 67 segundos estos segundos se
cancelan con uno de estos y todo nos va
a quedar en metros por segundo sacamos
nuestra calculadora y tenemos 29 puntos
y 9.8 por 5.67 y nos da menos 26.03
porque es este signo menos porque la
velocidad va hacia abajo vamos a
escribirlo así que eso es igual a menos
26.03 metros por segundo y nuevamente
ese signo menos viene de nuestra
convención de que las cantidades
positivas en la dirección vertical
indican la dirección hacia arriba y las
cantidades negativas indican la
dirección hacia abajo así que esta
velocidad final que encontramos
es hacia abajo justo en el momento en el
que aterrizó el proyectil cuál es
nuestra velocidad total cuando nuestro
proyectil toca el suelo bueno nuestro
componente vertical que va hacia abajo
es menos 29.03 y el componente
horizontal de nuestra velocidad no ha
cambiado en todo este tiempo sigue
siendo el mismo y recordamos que este
era 30 por coseno de 80 grados
lo voy a poner en el color correcto
y ahora voy a sacar mi calculadora para
encontrar este valor 30 por el coseno de
80 grados es igual a 5.20 94 nos
redondeamos a 5.21 así que esto es 5.21
metros por segundo vamos está en el
metros por segundo son vectores
velocidad y cuál va a ser mi velocidad
total bueno tengo que poner el inicio en
la punta de otro así que voy a desplazar
este vector acá lo voy a poner el inicio
en este otro vector vertical en la punta
del vector horizontal
este vector lo acabo de pasar hacia acá
así que la magnitud de este vector es
29.03 y aquí simplemente usamos el
teorema de pitágoras para encontrar el
vector velocidad final al menos para
encontrar la magnitud de este vector así
que la magnitud de nuestro vector
velocidad final aplicando el teorema de
pitágoras va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 5.21 al cuadrado 5.21 al
cuadrado que es la longitud de este lado
al cuadrado más la longitud de este otro
lado al cuadrado que es 29.03 al
cuadrado sacamos de nuevo nuestra
calculadora y tenemos que que la raíz
cuadrada de 5.21 al cuadrado mas 29.03
al cuadrado nos da 29.49 metros por
segundo lo escribimos esto es igual a
29.49 metros por segundo
la magnitud de nuestro vector velocidad
pero como es un vector también
necesitamos conocer su dirección así que
también necesitamos encontrar el ángulo
que en este caso va a ser un ángulo por
debajo de la horizontal o si lo quieren
ver en términos más puristas va a ser un
ángulo negativo que le voy a llamar teta
cuál es este ángulo bueno pues podemos
usar cualquiera de las funciones
trigonométricas para encontrarlo pero ya
que tengo estos elementos más visibles
pues voy a elegir la tangente podemos
decir qué
la tangente del ángulo es igual a lo
opuesto entre el adyacente
ese es mi ángulo el opuesto es este y el
adyacente es éste así que es igual a
29.03 entre 5.21 pero como nos interesa
el ángulo vamos a obtener la tangente
inversa en ambos lados y nos quedaría
que teta es igual a la tangente inversa
o al arco tangente de 29.03 entre 5.21
sacamos la calculadora y esto nos da
tangente inversa de 29.03 entre 5 puntos
21 nos da 79 puntos 82 5 que lo podemos
redondear a 79.8 así que esto es igual a
79.8 grados hacia abajo o podemos decir
que es debajo
debajo de la horizontal
de la horizontal
o menos 79.8 grados por encima de la
horizontal cualquiera de las dos puede
usarse y lo genial de todo esto es que
ya hemos encontrado nuestro vector
velocidad final ya conocemos cuál es el
vector completo
es 29 puntos 49 metros por segundo con
un ángulo de 79.8 grados por debajo de
la horizontal